let's rock baby as Dante would say
Alessandro let's rock so just so you
guys know happy Wednesday everyone I've
all isandro here first time in this
stream room at least he's been on some
other strange game of the year but you
just recently did impressions before the
game we're about to play which is a
Devil May Cry HD collection so I thought
it'd be appropriate to bring you in here
to not only play and showcase some hot
gameplay but to share your thoughts
outside of the written world yeah I got
to play through a development cry one
through three I played these games back
when they came out and I've been you
know just a longtime fan of the series
and you know it's it's it's been
interesting going back to these games
now you know when we're sort of used to
like sort of HD like aesthetics yeah
yeah this game is pretty the HD
collection is pretty much a upscaling of
all all three original games so it looks
pretty great for the most part but in
some case um areas it's a little iffy
but gameplay still intact
that's alright important why don't we
hop in we're gonna get through all three
games go is the the goal here so you
know we'll see how it goes we're gonna
start with that woman cry of course the
original the original you can start in
your game right you said probably yeah
let's do a new let's do a new game let's
do that is a Hideki Kamiya joint by the
way I don't say anything mean to them on
Twitter or else we'll block
I'm gonna go do something now no he's
kidding yeah yeah so I'll also be
monitoring chat if you guys didn't
already know that so we appreciate you
guys all tuning in if you guys have
questions for myself or Alessandro send
them on over and I'll get them to him so
hello to all the people hello Albert
Ramos Robo t-rex productions hey big fan
what's up snap JD how are you doing
hello deaf Thunder studios yeah loves
these games
how is DMC because I've never played it
is it like Dark Souls or blood-borne
it's actually not really dark Dark Souls
and blood-borne or more thoughtful
approaches like sort of action RPG games
well this game is a very stylized and
like sort of over-the-top focus on
action so you know there's a lot of room
for experimentation but also you have to
be mindful of like you know how you
present yourself and how efficiently you
attack I mean while that seems similar
to how things work in Dark Souls and
blood-borne them you have to be a lot
more conservative in those games yeah
you can't sort of necessarily throw
yourself into the action yeah yeah this
one is definitely I wouldn't say it
necessarily just rewards aggression but
you know rewards kind of the the combo
system it gets you to want to get higher
combos you know you start it like from
like I don't know like d4 doll and c4
goal it's like as you kind of rack up
the combos or do more do more moves
attack moves that's how you get like
higher points and I don't know do you do
you feel like you get more orbs that way
yeah that's actually how it works but I
like building up that style meter that's
actually how you gain more red orbs
which is used to you know upgrade your
characters for the weapons and skills
using the same move over and over or at
worst using only firearms actually gives
you the worst rankings which means
you're not gonna get as much orbs which
is vital for you know upgrading your
your move set and you know your weapons
you need to you know need to be like you
know chill and like really like you know
thoughtful and how you you gotta like
feel it yeah
a top mask 52 says it's like playing
Bayonetta absolutely it's pretty just
like being which was also a Hideki
Kamiya joint
don't know why I didn't draw that
analogy sooner my bad my B that's on
switch now by the way Bayonetta been in
the - you turned out great didn't know
that
PS PD 40 welcome back says again so I
have you played Devil May Cry 4 and also
the new version for the Xbox 360 with
the succubus I have I actually played
those I played every Devil May Cry game
when they came out so nice let me say
again I really love this series I got
you so Devil May Cry 4 is you know a
really great game it's possibly like
sort of peek DMC action in terms of like
the sort of mainline series I really
like the special edition that released
recently about two and a half years ago
now I think so
yeah I'm Ari does he mean a DMC from
ninja Terry as well I'm not sure but I'm
sure he can elaborate if that's what he
meant to say I thought that the knee DMC
was pretty good I don't play too much of
it personally I mostly played one two
and three and then I kind of stopped
after that for whatever reason I don't
remember why but yeah I really really
enjoyed a ninja theories uh take on DMC
I know that was a really contentious
thing with the core fan base but they
actually turned out to be a pretty great
game all things considered and the
deemed the definitive edition they
released afterwards sort of - around the
time the special edition for the mc4
came out was actually pretty great - and
it's like I wouldn't even say it's one
of my top favorite like DMC games ever
so pretty fair the pieman Hussein as you
guys think it's okay to encourage these
hacked-up remasters um I think that
depending on the remaster and now this
one's not technically a remaster right
it's not right because it's more of an
up ceiling right Capcom has been very
clear and saying that this is not a
remaster like in the vein of shadow
classes which basically redid textures
like you know basically the general
aesthetics of the game yeah make it more
you know presentable in sort of modern
sense
but again this game is just they needed
they wanted to bring this game up to you
know HD yeah you know standards like a
you know full like 1080p visuals for as
you can see this is still in four by
three because a lot of these a lot of
style the the sort of presentation that
the DMC games used were very much
designed around traditional yeah TVs at
the time when you're in four by threes
now mode but to get to the the question
I guess is that for me personally I feel
like if they do a good job of bringing
back a very classic nostalgia series
that some people might not have played
previously for for a not absurd amount
of money so this one's $30 yeah correct
which i think is pretty fair and you get
three games
um again maybe that's a little biased on
my point because I did play Devil May
Cry you know one two and three and I did
enjoy them but I think it's it's up to
you I guess it's as a consumer if you
think that it's worth your time and
worth playing so you know these these
you know remasters and kind of like in
this case like a HD kind of like
upscaling port it's up to you if you
think that it's worth it to you I guess
but for me I think it's cool to bring
back games that you know again as
mentioned either you and I played a long
time ago and loved and get to play it on
a newer generation of consoles or you
know for the for the people that didn't
know about Dante and maybe played like
Marvel vs. Capcom and that's their first
you know experience with with the
character or something ya know this is a
really solid way to enter the series if
you haven't tried them already and uh
yeah for the most part that I'm I feel
like the HD handling has been you know
pretty great the a lot of the games
unfortunately particularly from the ps2
era don't really age that well but DMC
has a particular style that just you
know to me just feels timeless like you
know it always works and this game
particularly the HD collection proves
that like so while there are some little
issues that I have with it I still feel
like it's a solid port so yeah again if
it's really up to you it's really up to
your own taste like you know whether you
feel like this is a worthy of the series
or not but it's a solid a way of
bringing these particular games to you
know the new era and if you guys want to
read more about Alessandra's thoughts
about the HT Devil May Cry HD collection
that article is also up on the GameSpot
so you know definitely check that out
not as not just calm you said I'm
playing Kate Kingdom Hearts remaster and
Devil May Cry HD collection because
there's no new games that interest them
Bane is out by the way yeah that too if
they have a switch which would be
shocking I guess if they didn't but you
never know
Robo t-rex production says emo Dante's
probably listening to my Chemical
Romance right now that's probably true
that's okay I like my Chemical Romance
what's up infinity 1 million how are you
paranormal Pete says Bayonetta is what
Devil May Cry should have been better
combating controls it's fair point I'm
just trying to catch up on chat cuz kind
of stop to answer that one question
which is a pretty fair one mm-hmm
especially like after playing I was
telling you before we started streaming
that like you know we just went through
burnout paradise and you know you do get
all the DLC but that's $40 and when you
told me this was 30 I was like oh
interesting
the only remaster missing this
generation is only Musha I'd I would
like that I agree I was like that
noctus commie that would be pretty cool
I also put those games until was it
three that had genre no I couldn't I
couldn't do it I don't know what it did
what put me on but something about it
they had a really weird time travel plot
like I think this sort of rubbed me the
wrong way yeah that was the one Onimusha
I didn't beat because I just couldn't
get through it I didn't want to I it was
weird
as a weird feeling for sure absolute off
yep I like it
Oh got more down the awesome thing is if
you guys didn't know and you play
Monster Hunter world Dante is making his
way to monster hunter world which I
thought was pretty cool
and if you haven't seen the trailer it's
pretty sweet because you know they do
whoever cut the trailer kudos to them
they you know they do D for drinking and
C for capture it was good it was good
but again that's probably biased DMC
from personally so low high Kang says
now dmc3 still the best I don't know I I
don't know if I could rank them would I
guess how would you rank them if you
were to rank all the DMC's in existence
I guess what would your including Ninja
Theory said sure okay double make our
three DMC definitive edition don't make
our one that will make cry for special
edition wow we're getting real specific
oh yeah don't my cry for then every wave
further down like DMC to like really far
down okay alright we'll get to that soon
though horse mango Phillips the third
says oh wow I love Dona Lucia three I
don't know man it just didn't work for
me oh I still enjoyed the game a lot I
mean it's a really solid action game and
I did like playing as John Bruno just
like the story itself just kind of
weirded me out and it just rubbed me the
wrong way amazing intro cinematic though
dustin bruce says i hope they make a
crossover where dante and bandana team
up that's like the dream everyone every
DMC fan wants that there's not bayonetta
fans i want it the other way i'm sure
yeah but but for the most part I feel
like everyone who's played Bayonetta
also played right well goop I know he's
Leon the professional and in that case
he's a genuine badass for me but in that
game it didn't do it for me so that's
those are two separate things man two
separate things
PSP d40 is asking GameSpot do you think
they should remake a Devil May Cry 4
with new missions and outfits and conv
sell to them they think it would
personally be epic I feel like I feel
like they should just focus on me
their next team see game whether that's
you know happening or not like I mean
we'll talk about Ruger we want to hear
like there was like there was like a
heavy rumor if you believe read it and
whatever that you know DMC was gonna get
shown off last year at e3 and then all
of a sudden sports like last-minute
decision they decided to hold it back
and not do it which then made a lot of
people think okay there's no way they're
not gonna do it this year
yeah right I totally Bank I mean
considering we you know just got the
release of this and also the monster
under tie-in yeah the timing seems right
so I am I personally think that you know
we could possibly seen be seeing
something this year hopefully my that's
my hope yeah do you think it'll be Ninja
Theory no I think it's gonna be capcom
again Tom because of the director of
dolma Cry 3 and Democrat for and also
Dragon's Dogma has been teasing
something for quite a long time it's
been saying that development has been
going smoothly and they'll hopefully
release information about it soon which
you know seems perfect for e3 got some
more stuff coming in queue
Bevo sorry if I put your name I wish
Nintendo Capcom will bring this DMC
series and then to be Nintendo switch
please hard to talk today yeah I think
it played I mean if bayonetta and
Bayonetta 2 worked pretty well on switch
I wouldn't imagine why this game went
into so who knows maybe yeah I think
it's perfect for the switch this is also
the first time in this particular
release of the port that it's gonna be
on the PC particularly adult my career
Devil May Cry 1 & 2
nice team C 3 had a PC port but a long
time ago and it was not great like it
was like really bad so you know because
criticisms about this aside this is
easily the best version of DMC 3 you can
play ok I'll take your word for it
reven 44 says for the next DMC would you
think it's is asking would you rather
play as the older new Dante it would be
cool if they mixed it like spider-man
charges dimensions older new Dante as in
ninja theories against Dante or I guess
it's like each iteration yeah yeah um
actually I wouldn't mind that idea like
you know just sort of like like you're
whining in the other yeah you just sort
of mix between or crossover so I think
it may be cool OB killer one asking what
happened to the lobby the lobby as a
show doesn't exist anymore however we
still have those kind of chats in the
office and we and we fill in those and
they come out once a week we don't
alessandro has been on one for far cry 4
car five as well as we've done other
ones you know in terms of puppy
fortnight is puppy starting to you know
be a little worried that fortnight's
kind of you know taken over in a sense
and those things still happen so you
should check out you know subscribe to
the youtube channel you'll get that once
one of those type of chats once a week
potentially more down the future but for
now definitely once a week so that's
kind of where we're at with that someone
said I would rather see a Kratos and
Dante crossover I guess that would kind
of work they both on that's the beauty
of this game is that it can work with
any pretty much any cross her idea that
you have like well within reason but
yeah yeah yeah like I mean I wouldn't
mind seeing Dante in Smash Brothers if
that's a thing they want to do yeah
that's fair we has been in fighting
games before no same with Trish and
Wesker oh why am i saying western cuz
western has a part of my Wesker was part
of my Marvel team that was full Virgil's
old Virgil yeah god I hate going NBC 3
he's too good he's a literal God when he
X Factor's anyways off topic well not
really totally off topic quick
noctus Kong he says I heard the needy
mc5 is actually right before DMC - I
mean speculation obviously but who knows
that could be a thing though I feel like
Capcom a sense sort of removed DMC -
from Canon like you know it didn't yeah
didn't happen well I I think beautiful
Joe actually made some jokes about it -
oh yeah correctly referring to DMC -
Dante
is like some other character in that you
know because Dante himself the original
incarnation of Dante made the parents in
beautiful Joe as a playable character
and there was a scene where one of the
characters describes how he looks
different in BMC - and Dante from dov'è
cry one is like I have no idea what
you're talking about it's good one they
play around you and no fan reactions are
and that the fans that really know can
kind of get get that that feel let's see
what you guys want multiple multiple
characters this is coming from Robert
Medina what do you guys want multiple
characters to play as for the mc5 or
just stick with Dante I would really
like multiple characters I'm I feel like
that's sort of but can't become a thing
that's standard entire story it's like
you kind of like get to a story point
then you're like oh I got to do weird
yes that or something yeah that was the
thing that you know happened more in
Devil May Cry 4 which was the first time
where they sort of integrated the sort
of multiple characters within the core
story because in dolma Cry 3 special
edition playing as Virgil was something
that you unlock after finishing Dante
story yeah I remember that part that's
cool
so if they expand on that in a proposed
DMC 5 and you know that'd be that'd be
pretty cool sorry
yeah we're seeing this getting a new web
desk cutscene but also just sort of sets
the tone for what this game just goes
about yeah doing
what's up hellstorm reaper hello welcome
Arthur watch I like this game how much
is it so this is one of three games that
you get in the Devil May Cry HD
collection and it's $30 hmm
do you want to see Nero again ask Dark
Lord yeah I think there was a really
solid character initially I was a little
hesitant about him when team c4 was just
sort of information started you know
coming out about it but playing him
Azzam was just a lot of fun I would love
to see him sort of expanded upon in the
next game if they'd if that's a thing
and so you know maybe do more abilities
with his a double bringer or maybe give
him something new there are new weapons
too because he only had the one
which got old after a while but yeah he
had a really solid move said I'd like to
see more of him in the future
dustin bruce says if they took the
original devil may cry and remade it
from the ground up with the gameplay
from DMC and rewrote the script and
recorded new voice actors i would fly a
pig the blue point to thank them i
mainly read that because of the blue
point point which you know they just
finished out over the classes and it's
already known but if they're working on
something else of which some people said
maybe demon fools that'd be great that'd
be awesome metal gear right someone yeah
some other people are like what about a
metal gear because they've I think
they've done some in the past but a lot
of people are still hurting over Demon
Souls as servers being yeah but at least
they live on in private servers
apparently that's not the same yeah I
know well that's not necessarily true
because if you look at what happened to
wow there are so many Wow classic
services like private servers for the
longest time that now look at blizzards
trying and I don't know how many years
out this is gonna be what they're trying
to you know bring that to life bring
back some way for people that just play
vanilla well I don't they don't even
know how long that's gonna take but they
just knew there was interest so you
never know yeah let's see and I'm also
interested on playing of playing Dark
Souls on switch which hopefully the
network test is should be soon ish
because the game releases in the main
they're the redoing the remaster
Oh what if no there's no way Platinum's
working on the next BNC right no I don't
think so that would be cool though but
like I don't I don't think so
also like it's all it's always weird to
talk about platinum because like I feel
like platinum spectrum for games can be
pretty wide like it give you like really
good or also like really not that good
yeah
like they got their eight they must have
like an a-team and like a B and like
maybe a CT yeah when you're looking at
sort of their a track record it's pretty
clear what's like you know sort of the
day this is the you know B team like a
Teenage Mutant Ninja yeah a lot of
people dislike Cora I mean I thought it
was all right you know it was yeah yeah
there wasn't as much anger with or like
I just remember that the Ninja Turtles
and thinking like oh cool platinum is
doing it now and then it was just like
oh this is not very good yeah and I'm
you know is this kind of said yeah I
mean that's like the game that should
have been good yeah it's actually coming
from platinum yeah and like you know
it's got a good franchise that a lot of
fans are behind and you know like yeah
their fighting style makes sense for
like a platinum game like yeah it's like
a prick like I thought it was gonna be a
good match you know if I'm depressed
formers - right that's why I was great
yeah I liked out there that was a lot of
fun yeah that's why I had pretty high
hopes for Ninja Turtles because I was
like oh this this feels pretty good like
surprisingly you know I didn't think it
was gonna be like it's got like a system
that's got like multiple character is
the only differently yep it was great
yeah I'm surprised we didn't get a
sequel out of that but yeah
Indian gamers do you guys think that DMC
Phi will be announced at e3 um I think I
want to say I think so I mean but that's
purely on the speculation if you kind of
believe the rumor which they were gonna
show it last year and if they were gonna
show it then you know it makes sense
that it would be there this year and
also as I think Alessandra I've
mentioned you know like having this HD
collection as well as having the Monster
Hunter tie-in kind of even more maybe
furthers the hypothesis or theory that
that could happen
what house I wouldn't mind but because
I'm a big fan but you know but again
like a cat
I'm sure we'll reveal something in time
yeah that's the mc5 or something else
entirely and like it wouldn't come out
till next year anyways because I was
thinking like oh but God of War is
coming out soon you know and in you know
in theory the the game plays like style
is similar right like a beat him up
action but yeah I wouldn't imagine even
if we saw it this year that it wouldn't
come out to like you know next year
anyway so but who knows that's all
speculation I have no idea I really want
to see Virgil and lady again in Devil
May Cry 5 or is it yeah I'm guessing you
met Virgil because there's definitely no
virgin yeah they in DOMA Claire for
special edition a lady and Trish and
Virgil were added to the game and
basically you know a lot for five
playable characters in one game which is
the most in any other in any DMC game
ever they all play differently and it
was it was a lot of fun playing ISM yeah
NK productions imagine DMC an open-world
game where you can ride a bike into side
quests working as a monster hunter sign
me up
yeah and it should also be stated that a
Hideo key at suno who worked on DMC 3 4
and Dragon's Dogma so he's got plenty of
experience and sort of open like you
know so open-ended style games so if
they want to mix you know DMC with a
sort of open world aspect then I he's
like the right guy to do it yeah what's
up mer Mari or Marie the B says hello
game so what's good what's good is that
it's a Wednesday and we're playing dead
when we cry that's what's good for me
I'm not actually playing I get to watch
curse nice if I said that right sorry Go
Go G yes thank you thank you appreciate
it and I go
gotta go to one
tat Tyler's only DMC 1 2 & 3 are in this
HD collection
any idea what's next for the DMT series
I wouldn't know I may be Alessandro
would have a better theory craft but I
mean basically what everyone's just been
hearing about like you know that's I
don't I mean it's really up to Capcom
whether they want to continue DMC or not
but I wouldn't I think would be great
you know to have another Devil May Cry
game like a full-blown Devil May Cry
game whether that's five or maybe ninja
there we have another crack at it I'm
always down for more DMC yeah I really
should go back and play the the Ninja
Theory one because that one was looked
pretty cool and I could it's right up my
alley yeah I really don't know why I
haven't yeah they've they received a lot
of criticism for how sort of the base
game turned out but a definitive edition
you know pretty much rectified much of
you know the sort of gameplay criticisms
understandably if the yet issues with
like sort of the general style and tone
of the story then the D the definitive
edition wasn't gonna do much to fix that
but I feel that of the game they made in
for the the updated version is fantastic
and it's still one of the best things to
come out of the franchise ever nice
switch over the show come where it sucks
- oh nice DMC this takes me back yes it
definitely goes which part is on now
we're playing the original that when I
cry the first time I cry and we'll be
going through two and three here in just
a second probably another few minutes
here will price which I forget is the
wolf boss right after this and actually
a phantom is coming up with okay Baba
spider boss oh okay are we close to that
yeah like we are right yeah we're coming
up all right
yeah well we'll probably switch after
the spider okay to your favorite that we
might ride to everyone's favorite
everyone's favorite real Mikey Mike
we're definitely not gonna beat it today
we're just gonna give you a little taste
of each each game mmm
Justin van Skyhawk I'm glad you're
playing this thank you for being cool
people thank you for
being a cool chatter and thanks for
watching yeah we appreciate it we
appreciate everyone that's hanging out
with us today and watching you guys
didn't know already we go live every day
at 11 a.m.
playing various things right now we
still have a weekly one where John Luke
and Ben will play monster hunter world
where you know you the community can
join in on some hunts and I think this
week which is luckily for John Luke he's
John Luke's gonna be out this week so
I'm actually subbing in and I was making
fun previously because they were making
an announcement about new monster coming
to the you know the world I was like I
bet you is gonna happen Friday when
you're gone he's like please no please
next week when I'm back and it turns out
it is actually next week so no Deb no
devil Joe hunting for me but maybe if
I'm lucky Dante will come out this
Friday I don't know if they've actually
said whether he's coming to wants to her
in the world but I'm looking forward to
that Mega Man you're gonna be able to
make your cat mega man at some point I
feel like April I feel like it was a
mistake showing that trailer and having
people wait extended period okay got so
you got me so many people excited yeah
the thing that tricked me and I I read
it wrong and everyone in in are like our
new slack channel had to correct me
there like I was like dude it's out
today and they're they're like no that's
like them telling you Monster Hunters
available now like wait so you're saying
Dante's not available now and they're
like no if you made that mistake then
I'm sure so many other people made that
mistake they rushed over to like yeah
PSN to see if there's an update or yeah
pretty much the first thing that got
into the office cuz I saw the trailer
was like oh sick I'm gonna go get the
Dante's skin right now it says it's
available now and I logged in I'm like
there's no new event quest there's no
new arena thing like where is it and
everyone's like nah dude it's just a
game being out lava spider then the
shadow being the wool and then Nero
Angelo yeah thank you a whole storm
Reaper that I just forgot I kind of knew
where what we where we were headed I
just kind of forgot because we recently
did this
John Luke did the I think the ps3
version when the when the anniversary
cuz it was anniversary this year right
I feel like that was my excuse for
playing it that day or having John we
play it was like that there's an
anniversary I have to double-check that
just so I don't don't make a lie don't
be don't be a liar no one likes the wire
tape no I know most people don't
Kirby's game says this game still looks
horrible crazy man crazy it's just an
uprise don't expect too much yeah but
even then it's there strolling I mean
this games got style I mean like you
know that's something that you know a
lot of games you know can't say after 15
or 16 years this game I think this game
16 years old now I'd have to
double-check this but Daniel Duke says
PSN has DMC one two three four special
edition for forty five if that's true
cool hey got baited part three sure I
got baited jebaited it happened boss
fight oh no it's the spider I remember
when I was a lot younger and I was not
as apt at video games this guy gave me
some prior this this guy gave everyone
trouble this guy I was like this was
like the this fight was like basically
the bar like you know you know that that
bar when you go to like the amusement
park right you can't reach this and
don't bother like it's weird though
because he he doesn't follow necessarily
the format like in terms of like your
combat like everything you've done up to
this point doesn't necessarily train you
for this guy because it's like oh I can
hack and slash this guy off and it's
like dink-dink it's like wait a second
ah I don't know Kirby's game I feel like
uh getting DMC one two and three even if
it's just an up res and not a remaster
for $30.00 is not bad in the in the
landscape of video games today but maybe
that's just me
maybe that's about that's the value that
I find fair but hey like I said it's it
should be what's worth it to you yeah I
got a professional here
professional demons killer I probably
did commentators curse happens all the
time
no wait till we get you for like one of
the one of those streams way more
stressful like like a neo or like a
don't put me on stream for neo like I'm
I can't read that Shion
unfortunately so I apologize I need a
trans translation for that guy for that
one
what's up anvil one gaming are you who's
baby at games by hack and slash games of
making a return in some form where we're
getting them in the in the forms of like
you know in this case a upscaling buggin
out for Bayonetta it was a you know God
switch so in some ways you could you
could say yes we're getting
hack-and-slash back oh I like a Tim Jim
give them the stinger to the face rabbit
94 J do you think Devil May Cry 5 to c3
that's what we were hoping and
speculating but you never know that
we're just going off the rumor ville but
maybe we know nothing
we know nothing concrete unfortunately
you think this is how closer you do the
the shadow not that close this is
probably good time yeah my favorite
version of the Gypsy DMC to where it was
like this far over you can see it
there's like a gauge of Alessandra's
devilment cross it's like going way off
its off screen it's off can we can see
any way you can so yeah it's gone what's
up epic epics games hello
oh yeah B oh no I would have got to see
probably so
that's pretty still passing room that's
true that is true for whatever reason
you know like see just has a negative
connotation yeah which is why and like
the funny thing is like I don't want to
get into reviews territory I hate it but
like that's why all these people are
like a seven that's like a see and it's
like no seven is like it's honor scales
good right is it good
I forget like there's always extra spare
yes good right yeah eight must be great
yeah all right here we go we're
switching over to Democrat I do like
that they added this handy back button
yeah back in the original release of the
HD collection 2012 for ps3 and 360 you
basically had to quit the game entirely
to switch over George Barbour channel
asking a good question is this trilogy
worth getting Alessandro what after
playing all three and sharing your
impressions what is your take on it I do
you know especially if you're a big fan
of the series and this is a really solid
way to play through each game on ps4
Xbox one and also the PC because again
these are the this is the first time
Doublemint cry 1 & 2 are gonna be on PC
and you're you can play you know DMC -
the best way you can on PC and you know
whether that's the thing you want to do
then you know absolutely do it alright
here we go
DMC 2 MC 2 Don't Tell Lucia no let's do
Don Taylor's yeah well just we'll just
keep it we'll keep it at Don tasting
alright
os are we continuing your save or is it
just anyone - are we gonna start from
beginning mmm that's the interesting
thing um even though DMC 2 gets a bad
rap it actually introduced a lot of
really amazing features for the DMC
games that they continued using from
then on which is the mission select but
also the weapon switching so DMC to
quality of life yeah absolutely
so DMC 2 was not a complete waste there
was progression there yes but we can
just do you know what let's just
continue off we're all right let's do it
mission 3 - is the worst oh we know
- is absolutely the worst nope
komm is even fest up Khan and ji-sun
says how how so how is it optimized good
or not for the most part the F frames
per second is rock solid like you're not
gonna have any slowdowns or anything I
did not experience any whatsoever
unfortunately there are some aspects of
the game that you know just you know
don't sort of you know translate well to
the HD like you know just going to the
menu you can see it's boxed off which is
a little off-putting but you know it is
what it is it's still not as bad as when
I mean like granted it was like a
remaster versus like this which is just
like upscaling and like you know better
frame rate but man ff10 I was telling
you guys how like I would look at walk
and be like sick walk is like redone and
then like all his buddies are just like
old just like polygonal boxed faces and
it's just awkward as hell yeah I feel
like I'm already tired of this jr. oh
really
yeah I say we gotta stick with it there
you and I'll cut your time for DMC let's
do it in half and then I'll give you
longer for DMC 3 let's just finish this
one mission alright yeah that's fair
that's how much you hate it that's fair
I I you know I won't what you do but we
got show a slice you know yeah a little
slice are you ready I'm ready
I've been ready I was born ready
Devil May gun says DMC 3 was probably
the best one yeah people feel that way
we're also playing me sorry I just write
a comment yeah go ahead hellström Eber
try getting through a couple levels of
knack as well as fighting the last boss
and knack then tell me if the mc2 is
worse than that we're only talking about
the series but that made me live so
that's fair now we'll say this game has
the best-looking version of Dante plays
outfits really cool yeah he also made
the appearance in a Shin Megami Tensei
turn wearing this outfit but he sort of
had the same personality from dmc1
because in this game in particular he's
sort of like more stoic and more he's
clearly not himself from the first game
like something happened like in between
matured a little like something tragic
happened must have happened this guy
uh-huh but well I'm tired of this
already XD you are not alone I trust me
m'kay production says DMC 2 is a good
game but with a bad story I like the
dark atmosphere in the art but the story
is so confusing yeah take that goat
winged goat Ling totally yeah it makes
me think small why I think you know Ling
but apparently the development of this
game was rather troubled because uh
after deep sea one was a solid success
solid success they wanted to try and
sort of follow up really quickly and uh
dmc1 came out in sort of the fall of
2001 and this game came out in January
of 2003 so not that they didn't have too
much of time you know to sort of pull
together a sequel and Hideyuki at SU
know who went on to direct this game and
dmc3 Democrat for and Dragon's Dogma so
was pulled into this project halfway so
he had to sort of make do with what he
had and unfortunately this is what
happened but he redeemed himself 100%
with dmc3 so all as well yeah
PSP d40 games are we watching God of War
3 or got a war ascension no plants
currently but maybe just because you
know got a war is coming out soon April
and we definitely will be streaming that
so maybe like a little precursor
beforehand might be might be not a bad
idea
like what is he doing what is this guy
doing he's climbing the monkey bars man
sorry monkey I know but like man I'm
just saying you asked me what he was
doing and I basically told you what are
you doing which is he was crying in the
mic
Dante is immortal right he can't die uh
he can die he's just you know he's just
highs really high durability he can take
a lot resilience
yes can you switch to d3 please l I've
had finished this mission jeez I didn't
know that everyone shared the hate
someone else at DMC 3 needs a remaster
yeah we need to show a little bit guys
come on I'm sure after this guy or ranga
ranga ah like an orangutan it was like
they were trying to mix a real attaining
something else gorilla I think oh girl
they thought they were really clever
with this boss but they weren't I feel
like the amount of damage you are able
to take of this game is way higher this
is this game is significantly easier
yeah it seems that way I don't recall it
being this easy they took many of the
criticisms about DMC one deepsea one's a
difficulty to heart
oh she's dropping glass on you Wow glass
awesome hey man that glass cuts have you
guys played Capcom's
chaos legion so underrated I did yeah I
actually really like that game there's a
it was strange like a just it was sort
of like this weird like light DMC light
uh-oh oh I almost got him don't worry I
know there's like DMC light cross with
like Dynasty Warriors but I mean it was
okay and when I see wraps it freaks me
out because I think like Dark Souls I
think blood-borne grabs hurt real bad
yeah that's okay like its overview yeah
exactly like napal boss grabs even one
of those games you're expected to lose a
third to half your life sorry I cut you
off there no no it's all good
yeah chaos legion was a interesting game
we never saw it again after that but uh
you know all right we're done nice
really that's it four minutes
we gave it all of like a like eight
minutes all right that's fair I I did
say you could get out after this mission
that's fine you know I
get out yeah I still have my PSP version
of this game DSD one is an awesome game
says game girl sexy dude I have to agree
with that
[Music]
Daniel Dukes would you rather play the
critically acclaimed Rambo from 2014 or
play DMC to start to finish well I never
played Rambo so that would be that would
be a new experience for me it was pretty
bad though I mean I'm always down for
just trying something new so K yeah I'd
do that over in DMC - I don't know I
probably do DMC - and suck it up as
weird as I don't know those are poor
options that's a whit lose-lose Daniel
Dukes let's be right here
Nero dust I can start what do you think
of the blade the DMC the latest reboot
of the franchise he would Alessandra
would have more to speak on that than I
would yeah we talked about we talked
about it earlier but I actually really
enjoyed a DMC 3 sorry a Dell DMC Devil
May Cry from Ninja Theory I thought it
was I thought it did a lot of
interesting like things with like sort
of the sort of iconic elements of what
don't my cry is and it taught it did its
own combat system like most importantly
because I was concerned about their
whether they were just going to sort of
rehash DMC 3 or even DOMA cry 1 but you
know it did its own thing and I really
respect what they did and I thought it
was a lot of fun like a particular
combat style they had was just sort of
like mono you're switching off between
angel and demon like two forms while
also working in sort the neutral like a
form so you're switching off between
three different like you know styles or
so I really enjoyed that like rewarding
you yeah very which is absolutely
something is something that you know the
series like the traditional series has
been about so I understand there's a
criticisms about like you know sort of
how they try presenting the game in like
you know whether the sort of humor or
like the drama they try presenting like
you know
whether that hot trailer scene yeah by
naked pizza flying by I mean like that
doesn't seem them too far out from what
della McCray has done in the past - the
nudity and stuff but but yeah I mean I I
really respect the game a lot the the
definitive edition is fantastic
like I highly recommend people giving
that a shot it's really great and you
know it's got two characters you can
play as Dante and Virgil and they're
both very different from one another
different from even like how they
appeared in the you know DMC 3 and DMC
for a special edition particular so yeah
I really like the game cool let's get
into the DMC 3 because a lot of people
dustin bruce bring on the DMC 3 to fill
my dark heart with light people Gupta
come on DMC 3 as well as I'm sure
there's a lot of others that were
probably echoing the same thing ms:i
complete the original well one
playthrough after that spider killed me
constantly uneasy and just switched off
then went back and played through
campaign seminars good yeah good job
good Congrats we're done with DMC to
rejoice yep this HD collection any good
ask juice blocks what are the notable
improvements HD like 1080p and and frame
rate it's rock-solid yeah just up res
it's not like a remaster or anything
just so you guys know sorry I'm just
trying to get through the chat as as we
can and of course as you guys know
there's delay
how rude that would normally killed most
people you like saved your life and you
just sure why well this is DMC bikini
yeah B Rose Diablo a king swot do you
think capcom will ever release another
Onimusha I don't think so not not for a
little bit my personal take you know
they're gonna have you know potentially
another DMC on its way and then there's
that ghost of Tsushima mm from you know
sucker punch so sorry you were gonna oh
yeah I like that every opening cutscene
for every mission points out the mission
number uh so when he wiped the blood on
the wall it's said it basically scrawled
out in seven yeah cool stuff yes as you
were saying yeah so like I feel like if
they were gonna do one it's not gonna be
any time soon however if for some reason
there's like you know a lot of success
especially with like you know got a war
or Devil May Cry and we kind of see a
return to those kind of like
action-oriented like sort of beat him up
style games then maybe but it doesn't
seem like it would be on the horizon
again that's just my take on I don't
know if that's right or wrong of course
but who do you prefer Virgil or Dante
that was covenant for me like I'm Dante
all the way and I like Virgil's style
but I feel like I need variety and
Virgil's like combat mostly focuses on
this a katana sort of J yeah I mean
that's cool but I mean I like messing
with like ice and nunchucks and like two
swords it's like that and talk and of
course like I like the firearms too so
it's always fun uh yes I have to pick
Dante I think I so when Marvel vs.
Capcom 3 first came out I was like oh
I'm gonna be a Virgil main you know
because I think Virgil is cool but I get
just the character itself never clicked
with me and then I have died so many
times the Virgil and x-factor that I
hey Virgil now so Dante a hundred
percent that's not really a great reason
but anyways it's Jay del bagel wants in
the Onimusha with John Renault again
nope don't want him get out of here when
was the last time he actually I feel
like that's one of the reasons why
they're not gonna release like an HD
collection for Onimusha because of
Licensing can they do one and two though
they can do one and two and four yeah
skip one yeah but then again like for
the third one was a solid game but the
we're really weird story but yeah I mean
people that's gonna be it's it would be
weird not to include that so I feel like
that's sort of ruining that reasons
that's like the potential thing that's
stopping them yeah definitely possible
the pool Gupta's you had mentioned on
English it was great still the best CG
intro ever on Russia 3 and then again
unfortunately you can't read your name I
think that's a Russian name ones kept
how I'm gonna make any volume movie who
knows I don't think it's going to will
they ever do an Onimusha HD collection I
mean based off of what you just said if
they were gonna do it it would have to
be this awkward dance of like one two
and four or like a one two maybe way
actually I think Delma sorry Onimusha 2
also included the likeness of an actor
'we know they all did i believe someone
owes gay was uh his visual like
aesthetic look was inspired by a
Japanese actor I can't remember the name
of great who's in House of Flying
Daggers Oh who's the lead the lead
character in that movie uh I want to say
it's Jet Li but I'm pretty sure it's not
it's a different different moment yeah I
know it's just I default to that that's
why Joe
oh it's a Andy Lau no no takeshi gagcon
said yes that's someone else gay someone
else care what is he what is this get
done was this guy done
I don't know any of these movies I think
I know here oh yeah well no it's the
wrong one here you think it's a
different hero yeah that I'm thinking of
yeah definitely different one man I
don't know any of these nope
so yeah I feel like that's one of the
reasons why they can't because of like
licensing like you know who the amount
of actors they use like you know throw
kraut juicebox Dave's never learned to
stop using lightness Oh celebs okay
there pi fans of the celebs yeah I mean
like I think it's cool that genre knows
and no no no Musha game but you know I'm
a little annoyed that's probably one of
the reasons why we're not gonna get
another release the old owner mushi
games Kay Bubo says who do you think
will Dante his girlfriend be Trish or
lady or both can't be Trish cuz she's in
the likeness of his mother and that
would be weird
nothing to stop him maybe he has a mom
complex
this is Japanese games after all man we
anime lady all the way one percent
alright interlinked media says I don't
think Onimusha was nearly as popular
that could be true yeah I feel like it
did it did well but not like gangbusters
like they did well enough for a forest
you know basically for games but the
fourth one I believe did not sell well
and that's one of the reasons why we
never got a follow up
I do believe that main character was in
a Tatsunoko vs. Capcom though that the
main character of twenty motion for
nothing I played for I stopped after
Jean Renault ruined it for me
it did some cool stuff you basically
could play as you know multiple
characters like five I think okay
character I'm actually thinking about
just trying to dig up a copy see Morgan
Roush in YouTube Chad says it's this is
simply a cash grab from Capcom if they
really want to do a proper issue you're
mastered then it would be redone like
shot with classes by Blue Point but they
haven't done well Blue Point is a very
popular dev right now because everyone
likes what they're doing we uh you know
they've done a lot of ports and stuff -
yeah I mean I don't I can't necessarily
argue that is clearly a cash grab any of
these like kind of like bringing them
back is definitely a cash grab it's just
at what price point they charged for me
that either makes me feel like it's a
little scummy versus not know and I
don't know again I'm probably biased to
Devil May Cry but 30 bucks for three
games doesn't seem bad yeah to me
personally but these guys yeah what is
that like a coffin yep
oh I don't remember this for some reason
really yeah I definitely remember the
twin swords and the nunchucks but I do
not remember the guy calling out souls
and stuff it just must be a while oh
there's a question that had both of our
names in it I got to read it at some
point
yeah where is it hey just Michael hi him
no it's not Michael hi I'm sorry I think
Michael hands a little Tanner than I am
Alan pairs a case why do you think Dante
hunting monsters is gonna be cool I
think so I really hope his armor set and
the I think it's a charge blade are both
high rank because if they're not in the
Ryu stuff it kind of makes them less
useful and you're gonna see less of it
so hard to say the a Lloyd stuff was
high ranked so at least usable and in
Monster Hunter but we'll have to see a
slain dragon 3 3 2 says I still have my
ps2 version of DMC one nice loving the
game or loves this game Dark Star spacer
there's no one that should be
necessarily banning you guys with dark
humor but it depends on what it is there
we do obviously moderate the chat so it
depends on the jokes or whatever your
you're making you could also play co-op
in the last Onimusha games as I blew
dreams oh cool
and you know that yeah I lost hunters
right there I'm I'm all a song we're
tight yeah he is reviews editor or an
editor I guess those reviews previews
plain old editor plain ol editor
jack-of-all-trades
yep Swiss Army I um yeah bad man Rick I
agreed that women cry on Monster Hunter
world looks crazy fun I think so it's
not have a feeling that the ebony and
ivory though in in monster hunter world
is probably new emote though thanks
Dante
Dustin Bree says this collection is $20
on ps3 $7 on the PS store sale can you
tell me any reasons to choose the ps4
version over the ps3 the ps4 version is
upscaled to 1080p while ps3 is still at
720 for the most part it's exactly the
same as it was warts and all
actually that's a good shout juice
blocks Frank West and Monster Hunter win
don't know but it's guy I like all the
Capcom crossovers though I lied I think
it's pretty cool and technically a low
is not a Capcom crossover and as PS wore
kind of like crossover but that was cool
like to see more that are viable though
I don't I don't want that just cosmetic
kind of thing because you know you know
armor sets to be viable well yeah
playing Devil May Cry 3 the third of the
games in the collection got you know
another 15 20 30 minutes you guys have
questions for Alessandra or myself
please put them in chat and if you guys
didn't know as I mentioned earlier we're
live every day at 11 a.m. and we
appreciate you guys tuning in chatting
with us
so if you haven't hit the sub button or
the follow button guys should do that we
we don't just live stream here at
GameSpot we got cool features we've got
our reviews of course previews
impressions all that fun stuff
I think Peter just put up Kirby
all-stars like is it allied all-stars
god blanking on the name I should be
more prepared prepared more Prince
Kirby Star allies there you go you just
put that review up I believe that game
comes out end of this week
Devil May guns what did you think of the
relatives Resident Evil series which one
was your favorite okay so I'm gonna
defer this one to all Asada - I never
got into the Resident Evil series myself
do i watching it of course but did you
play my progeny boy yeah of course um I
am is sort of a common answer but I
really like present evil for a lot I
know that's sort of the that's when the
series started going the more action
route but um just as a total package I
feel like it just has everything you
could want for an action game but also
for like you know even a Resident Evil
game like you know it's still offers the
scares and like the weird monsters and
you know just really corny story like
it's all there but as far as traditional
resonable games go there read the
original remake was a lot resin he will
remake was a lot of fun you just
incredibly like well designed game and
whereas evil 7 also was very very good
like I really enjoyed that game - that
was actually one of my top games of last
year - so really really just surprised
by how well that game you know just sort
of a handle - like how it approached
horror but also like you know a lot of
people to explore on their own like it
was really great as the High King said a
lot of people love Ari - yeah alright -
is great yeah well Bob Jones which is
better DMC or Bayonetta oh man I don't
want to get into that there are certain
things that I think that Bayonetta has
that I find cooler than DMC and just
like which time and like dodging being
like way more important but again I
didn't play too much of the newer Devil
May Cry so I don't know how much of that
is like in the system like you don't get
rewarded necessarily for like dodging
right like in the same vein that you do
in like Bayonetta cuz like that's a
pretty good deal
almost
for Nathan Shepard is our e3 and remake
mr. part always get into trouble on got
crystal skull
no no fight
nothing's free oh nothing not even in
the demon world yeah that's true low
high King Platinum Games entire body of
work is post EMC for so keep that in
mind that's fair
so I hope that in the new Devil May Cry
they reward you for dodging how many
weapons were in this one I forget
there's five double arms which are the
melee weapons yes that's why they fired
me away on five firearms so ten
altogether for Dante then Virgil has
three melee weapons the business sword
the gauntlets oh you have the gauntlet
and two sword combo I'm all about to
sword life except 90-100 world for
something
PSP these forties favorites Resident
Evil games are four and six someone else
was saying you could stand on the ball
and then attack no it worked out either
way and we're fine everything's
Abbey Jameson wants to know what kampung
franchise do you guys think most
deserves a collection sequel reboot
Onimusha so best
you took my answer I don't know let me
think I think hmmm trying to think of a
different oh I wondered that I would
played that I would want one of my own
mega rival schools come back
oh man that's never gonna happen well
although I guess I never thought ax was
gonna come back and then now we have Y X
layers the horizon so well I also didn't
think we were gonna get like you know a
Bayonetta 3 along with her oh oh yeah
that's right
uh-oh again a little sticky here this is
the worst part just do it
I'm gonna have to do it I'm sorry chat
yeah you failed chat they are all
disappointed no I don't know love for
Dino Crisis yeah Peter might have some
love for it I don't
there's Dino Crisis 3 which is gonna be
like a weird like wart on the whole
package but then again we have Democrats
who in this package so as for alright
why is it not awesome cuz there's three
levels of s it's so that's five like
there's a better way of describing
alright it's basically like you know
okay you're doing like this is like see
basically all right now we're power
stone crystal skull its Dreamcast though
right isn't there there's like a newer
Power Stone game I could have sworn
there is something that came out like
maybe last year that was like very
similar to Power Stone I was like oh
that's Power Stone yeah
jay-j del bagel says what weapon that
you can't wait to get in this game I
guess is that what he's trying on Evan
I'm assuming him like for this like
Nevin is the sort of the Lightning
guitar it turns into a scythe but it's
also a guitar I know that we're moving a
Marvel it's really good it's a good
assist when he does the guitar movie
comes on there's like a lighting guitar
it's really good
more like poser stonehack come on Dan
damn puns
Onimusha needs a Reeve thank you baby
you know what there is surprisingly a
lot of love for Onimusha in this chat
although i guess you would imagine that
like if we're streaming Doublemint cry
it makes sense that there's people that
probably like something we should see as
well sorry that's what I meant
that is a difficult weapon to master
Nevin that is you know that's why I like
it plus the boss wait you get it from is
a ferocious Marino so 60 FPS on console
yes right mm-hmm
rock-solid hadith I'll keep debating who
she needs another sequel I don't know
man we I don't think we're that close if
we are getting something on inertia
related maybe like years out especially
with that kind of similar but not you
know I still want to know more about
doses Tsushima I'm saying that right
does it feel like it's kind of I don't
know I don't know what kind of game to
expect necessarily but you know sucker
punch so you think infamous right might
pick in the right game here am i crazy
things to get the right game I think all
the times I was too busy killing a witch
- I said infamous yeah oh cool
didn't want to be wrong they also did
Sly Cooper before Sly Cooper one two
three these witches seem a lot harder
than the ones that you just shotgun and
be able to the first one we play cuz now
no dope yeah I still don't get how crazy
and then blast and then you have alright
you're just doing all roads what game is
this asked in in my foo now first second
or third this is third alright we
getting up to the next boss fight which
is yeah let's do it yeah we got time we
definitely have time at B Rouge Diablo
says I have Kane's about this game this
came to mind as a joke but do you think
it would be possible to start a petition
and ask game Capcom to make another
Onimusha
I mean you're welcome to I'm sure you'll
have people sign it but will they
actually like do something with it
probably not you're probably lucky if
for some reason somehow they were able
to do a like remaster or HD collection
that would already be I feel like that's
almost like the testbed to see like like
to gauge interest on a game like for the
longest time people were like
Darkstalkers Darkstalkers I want a new
Darkstalkers gave me Darkstalkers and
then they did like like the HD or
remastered version I can't remember
which one it is of that game and I don't
think it's sold very well and like that
pretty much tells them like oh okay well
don't like Darkstalkers yeah or as much
as like the the the vocal minority you
know are kind of chanting i guess but
like and that's the problem right
because then you realize or they realize
oh well guess good thing we didn't make
a new Darkstalkers yeah a lot of those
situations are also sort of its
dependent on timing too so like I'm sure
maybe the Darkstalkers we really sort of
came at a really weird time yeah
possibly
definitely j-dog bagels asked your most
annoying boss in devil McBride
you mean there yeah yeah I would say I
would think so the Leviathan heart which
is right after this actually we're just
gonna close
off of the virtual boss nod pentelic
says Democrat needs a prequel with
Sparta as the main character and how he
rebelled against a Mundus and imprisoned
his demon generals 4k 60fps coming on PS
5 sounds good sign me up sure the PS 5
that we don't even know if they exist or
not I mean like I'm sure eventually
we'll get a ps5 win who knows
oh I miss Darkstalkers taco come on man
not happening oh brother
and the only babe just left my sincerest
apology
I was so eager to see you
at any rate it's been a whole year since
we last met how about a kiss
[Music]
their jobs commute how about a kiss from
this still sounds like anakin
skywalker's when they call
should reward noting that both virgil
and dante are portrayed by former power
rangers oh really
yep Ruben Langdon used to be one of the
Power Rangers in the original Japanese
series who's one of the Western students
who became a Power Ranger which Ranger
was he I can't remember but there's
clips of it online where he's like on
the show damn and Virgil is such a
badass though I don't know what it is
it's his swag oh yeah oh yeah and then
you got a B what are the odds of that
happening all right give me some s he's
motivated by the way Oh
graphic slash nightmares I'm getting
nightmares of Marvel right now
Oh which way do I block is there forward
backwards by only with rebellion please
all right I don't know that was just a
commenter you don't have to do it you do
whatever you want
look I'm winning everything's fine oh oh
yeah just like Marvel baby those like
half full screen slashes OH
ooh they gets more intense later on so
awesome I'm illiterate I'm actually
having like PTSD of like Marvel right
now
j-dog bagel says what do you guys think
of ninja series version of Virgil Doh
smiley face I like who will win the life
is closed oh we're good how come Virgil
doesn't do that Virgil would use some
help we cheated you should too I'm just
kidding
yeah got him with that dope combo
success doesn't Bruce wants to know what
is your favorite weapon from the series
mine is the mystery box from three yeah
was he's trolling yeah well actually the
dopa cry for it did have the Pandora's
box weapon which was like the suitcase
that would turn into like a mini gun the
laser cannon bladed like for meringue
type thing it was really weird there's
like the weird weapon that comes with
every DMC game but yeah that was a lot
of fun I I mean I'm new I'm traditional
I like just the generic sword like which
is like in this game is rebellion
Delmon cry one heads or the balusters
and force edge which eventually became
the sparta sword which was the weird
boomerang type weapon yeah yeah I mean
like I like I like swords man thank you
know what a stick with that bosun says
gg he was the one that told you just use
rebellion so good job Thank You Fulton
pad man Rick says Virgil's hardcore he
does not need health restoration though
I don't know he lost there well not
really I guess
my team and Pandora's box it should be
noted that according to Nathan Shepard
he did start with less you started with
less help okay
fit that Phoenix we answered this we
both picked Dante for various reasons
him because he played Dante it's hold
life loves Dante I just have PTSD of
losing to Virgil so many times when
we're overs Capcom 3 but I can't we have
the vertical training anymore so Dante
oh you think this is a good time this
sort of summing up once this cutscene
goes oh no he's so sword to you
Oh still good yeah brother wouldn't
leave you without a weapon
[Music]
they see a double inside you has
awakened as well we should leave for the
moment we have all
ah
night-night
fun times yep well on that note as Dante
lays there and his old full of blood
just want to wrap up the stream of
course thank you everyone for tuning in
appreciate it this is a Devil May Cry HD
collection it's out on the ps4 PC and
Xbox one so you can check that out if
you want to $30 also Alejandro has kind
of written up some of his impressions
you know of the game and how its kind of
you know how good it is now I guess it
was it worth it I guess I could speak to
that better than I can
yeah I understand people might have some
sort of apprehensions about it but for
the most part it's a really solid like a
sort of port and on to the ps4 and Xbox
one and PC again it is just an upscale
it's nothing like substantial like stuff
that a Blue Point that's done for the
closets it's they didn't redo textures
or menus or anything it's just an
upscaling to 1080p but rate and frame
rates yeah six frame rates solid 60fps
it's great you know but yeah the
gameplay is still solid and it playing
through this a game playing through this
game again was a lot of fun and yeah
it's a solid port yeah so check it out
if you guys want to but be sure to come
back tomorrow 11:00 a.m. we'll be live
again we appreciate it of course and
until next time and until we get all
isandro back in here I'll see you guys
later
thanks Andrew thank you